You know, it's really hard to make a drawing stand out,
if it's only in black and white.
We can change the colors of fills and
strokes by using these two, fillStyle and strokeStyle.
We can call fillStyle on the canvas context and in this case,
we're going to set it to blue.
You can use a name color.
There are a 140 name colors, according to the HTML specification.
And you can learn more about them in the instructor notes.
Or you can use a hexadecimal color.
So in this case we're setting the stroke style color to 33CC33.
And we're calling it on the canvas.
Hopefully these two should add some color to our drawing over here.
Let's find out.
I will save it.
I will come over here and hit Refresh.
And we see that in fact the fill actually did become blue.
Our triangle is now blue, which is pretty cool,
but it looks like strokeStyle here didn't have an effect.
This hexadecimal color should be a shade of green, but
we don't see any green over.
And that's because, fillStyle and strokeStyle.
Only applied to the fills and strokes that come after them, inside your script.
So in this case because we're calling fill,
after we set fillStyle, we have a nice blue triangle.
But because we drew our stroke rectangle,
well before we set the strokeStyle it didn't get affected.
Let's go ahead and change that.
So now we set the strokeStyle to this color before the rectangle.
And we should see green rectangle instead.
So let's save our script, come over to the browser and
hit Refresh, and now the rectangle has a nice, light green outline.